did you shop in Italy was your favorite
designer brand Italian what do you think
this because you were a lot of nice
Italian things I am a simple man who is
mostly Sears go ahead we ended up
working I was incredibly impressed this
is the first travel show that I've ever
been on and I was incredibly impressed
by the schedule that the crew keeps I
mean they're really working all day long
so there wasn't a lot of free time but
you know in general I actually don't do
a lot of shopping
when I travel I don't come back with
souvenirs I usually pack a carry-on bag
only maybe the souvenir I would get
would be like a little espresso cup or
something like that from my favorite
cafe maybe I got you something you
remember I guess yes there was a coffee
shop in Florence which for some reason
didn't want a shooting there so he ended
up not shooting there but I had told
Conan it was my favorite he remembered
he went without me he bought me our very
expensive Italian porcelain cappuccino
cup and gave it to me I was blown away
that he remembered the place and then he
was so thoughtful to get the cup I just
want to get that story out there
[Applause]
you